deku's new form is freaking awesome but
is he about to attain Quirk Singularity
and destroy shigaraki or is the villain
about to steal all of deku's quirks
right here and now I can't believe that
Deku is making this insane gamble that
reveal at the end was just crazy so
let's get into it you guys all this
works if you enjoy my mha content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like right now for that YouTube
algorithm and listen to me right now
guys we are literally like 4K away from
2 million subscribers do me a huge favor
and And subscribe right now we're so
close the previous chapter featured Deku
using whatever creative methods he could
to get the better of shigaraki in battle
he was especially relying on black whip
both to trick shigaraki's newly acquired
danger sense and to envelop his own body
with the black whip tendrils in order to
allow himself to keep moving even after
pushing himself past his own limit he
basically used black whip to reinforce
his muscles and tendons from the inside
essentially fusing black whip to his
body overall de once again showed
amazing skill and combining all of his
different quirks together in order to
hold his own against the overpowered
monster that is awakened shanaki Deku
even managed to smash shigaraki's arm
into pieces but the villain was able to
easily regenerate and he also used ragd
doll's former Quirk search to fight back
against deku's clever diversionary
tactics the focus of the chapter then
shifted to the fact that Deku still
wants to save little tenko shimura from
the clutches of what tomura shigaraki
has become shigaraki is insulted by the
very idea that he is still t on the
inside and he shows deu and the one for
all vestages the inside of his vestage
world where he says he overcame and
buried little tenko inside a dark
concrete sphere shigaraki says that
tenko is dead and he is in control his
worldview is in control and trying to
save tenko is utterly pointless even
Nana's vestage tried to convince Deku to
stop trying to save her grandson some
people can't be saved and Deku has to
destroy shigaraki as soon as possible
but Deku refuses he says that tomura
didn't overcome tenko he simply put a
lid on him by burying him inside that
dark sphere Deku vows to shatter that
lid to Pieces by any means necessary and
he refuses to give up no matter what at
the very end of the chapter came a crazy
twist as all might's vestage saw a star
and Stripes vestage still inside
shigaraki's vestage world she pointed to
a crack in shigaraki's dark sphere
implying that the sphere can in fact be
broken and that tenko can be rescued the
second user believes that the only way
to achieve this is from inside shigaraki
the only way to achieve it is to allow
shigaraki to steal even more of one for
all and its Quirk factors the latest
chapter starts off with a quick
explanation for why we saw star and
stripe at the end of the last chapter
back when New Order had infiltrated
chiaki's all for one vestage world and
started attacking its Quirk factors from
the inside star noticed that there was a
sad child in there she saw the child
through a crack in that dark metallic
sphere that shigaraki had constructed
which seemed seems to prove that deku's
theory was right tomura didn't actually
overcome tenko he simply hit him away
and put a lid on him now for some reason
the real Al might seems to be also
getting this information as if he was
having a vision of star and stripe it
could be that something is happening
with his connection to his own vage
inside of one for all or it could be
that one forall itself has begun to fall
apart after shigaraki managed to steal
the fourth user's Quirk Factor all might
is clearly worried that something bad
could be happening to the one for all
Quirk and if something bad does happen
deu and all of Japan are basically
screwed because shigaraki will destroy
them all back on the battlefield Toma
also saw the vision of star and he is
confused as to why she would be there
because he knows that he already
destroyed her in battle one possibility
is that the star he is seeing is an
ember of new order that has stuck around
inside his vestage world even after
star's physical death I mean we already
know that this kind of thing is possible
with one for all and its vestiges so I
wouldn't be surprised if the same type
of thing could happen with star
meanwhile deu is taking a beating from
shigaraki but all the while he continues
to talk to the second user Kudo he asks
Kudo what he meant by what he said at
the end of the last chapter why would he
say that the time has come for Deku to
part ways with one for all Kudo explains
that the dark metallic sphere that
chiaki showed them inside his Quirk
Factor represents all of the anger and
frustration of his past and all the
traumatic memories that made him who he
is today he has managed to bring all of
these negative emotions together in
order to create a solidified sphere of
hatred that motivates him to keep
fighting with Incredible will and
determination but all might's vestage
realized that there was a crack in that
sphere the crack that showed itself
during the fight with star the crack
that proves that tenos shimura is still
in there somewhere deep within the
sphere of hatred because this crack is
an internal mental wound for shigaraki
he can't just use super regeneration to
fix it and so Kudo believes that this
crack is the best hope they have of
actually defeating shigaraki the villain
is too strong to be defeated from the
outside in terms of physical power he is
practically Unstoppable but if they can
transfer one for all to shigaraki in a
way that increases the size of the crack
until the entire sphere breaks they will
be able to reach his true Consciousness
they will be able to reach tenos shimura
this is insanely risky of course but it
may be the only plausible way of
actually defeating shigaraki before he
destroys Japan not everyone agrees with
this plan
and and in particular thinks that this
could backfire instead of being hurt by
the transference shigaraki might just
absorb one for all and use it against
dein battle which would result in
complete defeat for the heroes and in
the complete destruction of all of Japan
but Kudo believes it all depends on how
the transfer is made if they do it right
shigaraki will take damage and the crack
within the dark sphere of his psyche
will widen but yes it is very risky and
that's why Kudo volunteers to allow
himself to be absorbed by shigaraki next
in order to to test the waters when the
fourth user's Quirk Factor was stolen
deu still got to keep the rest of one
for all including all of its accumulated
power so they can now do the same thing
with Kudo and gearshift and is worried
that if the villain is able to use
gearshift against Deku then it's going
to be all over so he actually suggests
that he should be the one to go because
if shigaraki uses his Quirk smokees
screen that won't be that much of a game
changer and it won't affect Deku as
negatively as an attack with gearshift
but Kudo believes that if gear shift is
transferred to shigaraki then all of the
recoil that comes with it will be
transferred as well if shigaraki tries
using gearshift then he will be the one
to feel the recoil from Deku repeatedly
overusing gearshift instead of Deku
himself at least that's the way that I
understand it and that will then do
significant damage to shigaraki so it
could actually help deu in battle even
Bruce the third user is skeptical of
kudo's strategy and Kudo agrees that yes
it's a huge risk but with how things
stand now with deu exhausted and pushing
himself to the Limit and shigaraki
intent on destroying all of Japan
fighting the villain from the inside
seems to be the only way Nana then steps
in and says that deu is hesitating to do
this not because he's afraid that he
won't be able to win without gear shift
but because one for all is so special
and important to him this is not just a
quirk to him it is a precious gift that
he received from his Idol and it is the
thing that allowed him to fulfill his
dream of being a hero so the thought of
willingly allowing even a part of one
for all to be taken by shigaraki is
absolutely Terri Ying to him but the
time for debating quickly ends because
shigaraki attacks once again and Kudo
tells banjo and yoichi to take care of
Deku as he attempts to carry out his
risky plan Kudo then tells Deku that the
rest is up to him and asks him one more
time if he's willing to do this Deku
says that yes he is and in the very next
moment a bunch of black whipped tendrils
Rush at shigaraki and rip his right arm
off once again in the final panels we
see that Deku has attained a new form a
form in which he has essentially merged
his body so closely with black whip that
the tendrils appear to be a part of
deku's body they are interwoven with his
muscles and tendons they pop out of his
body like extra appendages ripping his
shirt in the process and they even seem
to take the form of a Dark Mask around
his face even shigaraki is shocked by
deku's new appearance and he says that
right now Deku doesn't look like a hero
at all and I guess he's got a point
deku's new form looks very dark almost
like a Venom deu or spawn deu but aside
from looking dark and cool I wonder what
this form can actually do has Deku now
attained the ability to merge his body
with black whip to an even greater
degree and if so what kind of new powers
do you think he might possess give me
your thoughts and theories down in the
comments if you guys watch my videos
regularly then you know how long I've
been saying that I would like to see
Deku unlock Quirk Singularity where all
of his different quirks stop being
separate quirks and merge into a single
super Quirk that combines the elements
of all the other quirks but also has its
own unique powers and abilities withu
learning to combine his quirks more and
more effectively and with him now
unlocking a new form by essentially
fusing black whip to his body I think we
might be heading to the point of Quirk
Singularity with deu and honestly I
can't wait to see what deku's
potentially World crushing super Quirk
would actually look like but while we
can speculate about deku's powerups we
can't forget the crazy strategy that the
heroes are apparently planning to adopt
they want to willingly give up more one
for all quirks to shigaraki starting
with gearshift in order to go and fight
the villain from the inside this is
exactly what I predicted would happen in
my previous chapter review but
predicting it doesn't change the fact
that this is a massive risk and it could
backfire catastrophically what do you
guys think is the risk of this strategy
worth it would you risk it if you were
deu let me know down below if you're
looking for another epic M video to
watch next check out our video where we
ranked the 13 strongest multiple Quirk
users in the series link on screen and
in the description if you enjoy my M
videos you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like to let me know
and once again we are only like 4,000
subscribers away from 2 million do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are so close